hi i'm evan carmichael and today i want
to do something a little bit different
usually i do profiles of famous
entrepreneurs and the top lessons you
can learn from their success
or i'm answering a question for one of
my readers today i want to share a
little bit about my story
and how i became an entrepreneur as well
as a program that really helped give me
the confidence to start my business
in the top three lessons that i learned
from that program i hope you enjoy okay
so here's a little bit about my story
i've been an entrepreneur as long as i
can remember the first
memory that i have to be an entrepreneur
is when i was five years old
i convinced my three-year-old little
sister to draw some pictures with me
with crayon
and then we went door-to-door trying to
sell it and we made our first
sale to our neighbor for 10 cents and
i've been an entrepreneur ever since
most of the business that i had early on
didn't go anywhere
baseball card businesses you know i made
a little bit of money extra spending
money but
i weren't really businesses it wasn't
until high school where
i joined a program called junior
achievement that really gave me the
confidence to become an entrepreneur
and what junior achievement is is they
have 40 kids that they get into an
after-school program
called the company program and they
launch their own company
and you have to come up with a product
idea you have to elect
a president and vice president you have
to do a business plan you have to raise
capital
basically all the things that you have
to do to run the real business but
you're in high school
and you've got some mentors from
different companies to help guide you
along the way
and so junior treatment really gave me a
lot of the confidence that i needed to
start my business
when i got to university i remember not
having anything about entrepreneurship
until i got to a fourth year course and
in that class
i had already done most of the stuff
that they were teaching in my junior
achievement program when i was already
running my business
so i really give junior treatment a lot
of the credit to me wanting to start my
own business and to the success that
i've had
as an entrepreneur and so i thought i
would share the top three lessons that
i've learned from my experience with
junior achievement
that have helped me grow my business
so the first lesson that i learned was
you have to sell
i was in junior achievement for three
years and some years we had
really good products but bad sales
people on our team
and we didn't really go anywhere with
our company and in other years we had
not so great products no decent products
gift baskets these aren't high-tech
products it's high school
but we had a really good sales team and
we were a lot more successful
and selling isn't really a skill that
they teach you in school but it is a
really vital
life skill that you need to be
successful as an entrepreneur and
as even a professional and so i really
credit junior achievement for giving me
that skill but you have to really think
about in your organization
selling you need everybody to know how
to sell in order for your company to get
to that next level of success
the second thing i learned from june
achievement is get big corporate orders
when we first started we tried to sell
to our friends and our family and
basically every
everybody that we knew who would you
know maybe we could guilt into buying
one of our products
then we quickly discovered that we were
out of friends and family to be able to
sell our stuff too
and sales dried up so we had to figure
out other ways to vote and
and get orders and my most successful
year of junior achievement was when we
were able to get
a big corporate company to make bigger
purchases and so we had fewer clients
but
they made a lot more purchases and it
was an ongoing type of transaction
so with your own business something i
still think about today a lot of people
are struggling trying to sell one-off
deals to customers who may not come back
or maybe a long time before they come
back again
and it's really time consuming but if
you can go and get bigger orders
that are more dollars for you and could
be an ongoing type of deal as well
it's much more profitable for your
business
the third thing i learned from junior
achievement is get everyone involved
in a junior achievement company you
might have 40 high school kids in the
program
and there's only so many management
positions once you let your president
and all your vice presidents everybody
else are just workers in the company
and it's really important that you make
them feel involved and and
an important part of the company or
they're going to leave the company and
it's just going to be the management
team that's left
and that's important lesson for your own
business you might be by yourself now
you might have a couple people around
you
and you're if you're the founder of the
business you're going to care way more
than everybody else
but you want to make sure that everybody
does feel like they're attached to the
company and they feel that they're
important they feel like what they're
giving
is a meaningful contribution and they're
happy about what they're doing with your
company
the more you can make it feel like
employees are really happy with what
they're doing and that what they're
doing is really important
the more likely you're going to get
better workers you're going to retain
them and your company is going to grow
so junior achievement helps over 250 000
students here in canada and many many
more around the world
wherever you are there's probably a
local june achievement chapter close to
you
and i encourage you to check it out and
get involved and be a mentor
to the new up and coming generation of
student entrepreneurs
so that's it for today thank you for
joining me for this video if you enjoyed
the video please give it a thumbs up
i'd also love to hear your thoughts and
feedback if you want to leave a comment
below and stay tuned for the next
episode
you